こんにちははじめ社長
ですこの動画はえ僕から皆さんに大切な話
があって動画を撮ってい
ます私はじめ社長がえ企画部長という名
でゲームの開発や企画に携わらせて
いただいておりましたスマホゲーム上長島
人年のみこのサービス終了
することになりまし
たこの期間遊んでくださった皆様本当に
ありがとうございまし
た
うん悔しいですね今回はですねこの動画で
サービス終了に至った理由や経緯をお話し
したいと思っておりますそもそもはじめ
社長がゲーム作るのに関わってたんだって
いうのを知らない人もいるかもしれないの
でえ簡単にちょっと説明だけさせて
いただきますすいませんちょっと要点
まとめたので紙を見ながらお話しさせて
いただきます僕と神流島っていうゲームの
関わり方についてお話ししたいと思います
そもそもなんではめ社長突然ゲーム作った
んだって思われていた方もいらっしゃると
思うんですけどもあのお話をいただきまし
て初めの好きなゲーム作ってみてはどうで
すかてそれでもちろんゲーム好きなので
そういうこともやってみたいなと思って
今回の企画に参加しましたもうこの時点で
はどういうゲームを作ろうとか何にも決め
てないままあでも面白そうだからやってみ
ますっていう気持ちでえスタートしました
これがね2021年の7月ぐらいの話です
もう2年以上前の話ですね僕とこの
プロジェクトの関わり方についてなんです
けれどもま本当ゲームのコンセプトだっ
たり世界観キャラクター監修などメインに
担当させていただいておりましたなるで
本当僕が好きそうなゲームになっていたと
思うんですよ神流島っていうゲームが
アニメひぐらしの泣く頃にとかそういう
ホラーも好きだだし美少女系のアニメも
好きなのでホラーかける美少女っていう
ゲームちょっと作ってみたいなとあんまり
ないと思っててスマホでそういうゲームが
なのでホラーかける美少女っという軸で
コンセプトをまず揃えてでそこから色々
こうアドバイスをいただいたりあのゲーム
開発のプロの方もいらっしゃるので
いろんな会議をこう重ねに重ねて美少女が
呪われた島から脱出するという設定となり
ました美少女キャラには職業があった方が
面白いなと思ってこう女子高生だったり
自衛官だったり保健室の先生とかいろんな
キャラクターをみんなで考えて
キャラクターを考案させていただきました
そういう感じでゲームの開発を主にしてい
たというよりこういうゲーム作りたいこう
いう感じにしたいこういう世界観でやって
みたいですっていうのを僕から発信して
それでもっとこうした方がいいんじゃな
いっていうのをこうプロの方からいいたり
お話を戻していただいたりして考えてでき
た世界観それが上流島というゲームでここ
からはですねゲームのリリースから
サービス終了に至るまでの経緯をお話しさ
せていただきます
出だしはすごく良かった
ですまはめパワーもありサービス開始して
速攻でゲームランキング1位を獲得する
ことができましたで6月の15日から
ひぐらしの泣く頃にコラボもスタートして
立ち上がりとしてはかなり良かったのでは
ないかと思い
ますうん最初はすごい良かったですねいや
ゲームランキング1はすごいことですよ
その時点でなんか僕はあみは良かったなっ
ていい感じだなっていう気はしていたん
ですがその後ですねえーゲームの
マッチング部分にねちょっと問題があり
ましてゲームがうまく遊べないっていうの
がすごいたくさんこうご意見として
いただきました神長島どういうゲーム
かって言うといわゆるあの非対称型ゲーム
鬼川と人側に分かれて遊ぶゲームで逃げる
人が4人追いかける人が1人で合計5人の
人がマッチングしないと遊べないゲームに
なってたんですよ逃げる側が可愛い少女で
追いかける側がね神と呼ばれるちょっと
怖いグロい恐ろしい見た目のキャラクター
で遊ぶゲームだったんですけどもここでね
バランス調整がかなり難しくて追いかける
側をやる人がかなり少なくて逃げる人4対
1の4人側にすごい人が集まっちゃって
そもそもゲームが遊べないマッチングがし
づらい状況がえ続いてしまっていましたで
これねあの僕も覚えてますすごい焦りまし
たああリリースしたゲーム遊べないんだっ
ていうそもそもマッチングが成立しないと
遊べないゲームだからもうゲームの開発の
人になんとかなりませんかっていうのを
言ったんですけども開発の人はもう本当
必死になんとかしようと思って本当に
頑張ってくれたんですがやはりリリースし
た瞬間にね遊べないっていうのは結構
大きな部分だったかなと思ってそこで
ちょっとちょっとだけやって抜けちゃっ
たって人も多かったのかなと思いますなの
でまずゲームをちゃんとプレイできる
遊べる環境を作らなければということで
そこを最優先に動きましたでねこれは僕
リリースするまでは本当に無知で申し訳
なかったんですけどもゲームのそういう
バグとかミスとか改善しなければいけない
ところを直す時ってものすごい時間と労力
がかかるんですよそもそもマッチング
できるようにしときやって言われればそこ
までなんですけどもそうなってしまった時
に直す時に本当にねすごい時間がかかって
しまってせっかくインストールして
くださった方にはちょっと申し訳なかった
んですがらくねうまくマッチングができ
ない状況が続いてしまっておりました
もちろんマッチングだけではなくいろんな
部分でこう直すべき点とか修正点はあった
んですけれどもやはりゲームの開発には
多額のお金がかかったりしてしまいます
これ以上サービスが続けるのが難しいと
いう経営判断になってしまいまして
サービス終了が決定いたしました悔しい
ですそして今も遊んでくださっている方が
いると思うのでここでサービス終了になっ
てしまうのが本当に心苦しく思います
ごめんなさいサービス終了したしたものの
個人的にはすごくいいゲームができたなっ
て思ったので開発に携わってくださった人
にはとても感謝しています今日ねちょっと
リトマスっていうその企画を持ってきて
くださった方の偉い人がいるのでお話しし
てみますリトマスの北条さんですよろしく
お願いしますお願いしますすいません僕の
力不足でいや悔しいですねいや本当悔しい
ですねあのやっぱ出来上がったもの自体は
すごく良かったと思うんですけどやっぱり
なかなかゲームってのはビジュアルとか
キャラクターがまいいだけじゃうんうん
うんやっぱダメで
やっぱなかなかこうまたいろんな何人もの
人が関わって作ってくのでそういう色々
難しさがありますいやこうしてくださいっ
ていうのをパッてこう言っても複雑なわけ
じゃないですかゲームってそうですねそれ
が反映するのにもすごいやっぱり人と時間
とお金がかかってるんだっていうの
めっちゃ感じちゃって途中から言い
づらかったですすませんいやでもすごい
いい経験をさせていただいたなと思って
ますねありがとうございます神島をやろう
ってなったのがちょうど2年半ぐらいです
もんねそうですね2年半ぐらい前で
マッチングしないとかそういう話を覗いて
当時だったらわかんないですけどもう
ちょっと売れてたなて思ってるんですよ
はいそうですね流行ってませんでしたか
期待象ま待象だけも本当にまデッドバイ
デラか第5人格とかますごく流行ってた
時期ででま元々まこうリトマスでもあの
脱獄ごっことか書型のゲームであの非常に
こうまノハあったのであの当時はもう絶対
行けるだろうとんそうなんですよ来たと
思ってホラと美少女の対症型ゲームないや
んと思って意外とありそうでなかったえ
そうなんですよいいとこつけてたなと思っ
たんですけどはい2年ぐらいってゲームの
トレンドって大きく変わったなと思って今
なんか混沌としてませんゲーム結構そう
ですねやっぱりまそれこそ中国のまゲーム
の会社さんとかがますごいこう対当してき
てうんうんまかなりこうクオリティの高い
ゲームがどんどんこう出ていく中ですごく
ライトなゲームがこう出たりとかまこう
うん2局化がまこう進んでいく中で
ちょっとなんか我々としては中間をこう
狙っていくようなうん形で攻めたかったん
ですけどタイミングもその当時は良かった
けどっていう部分もあったような気がし
ますねそうですねやっぱ移り変わりが本当
に早いですいやそうすよねかと言って
ゲームの開発ってすごい時間がかかるもの
なのではい本当にありがとうございます
いやいや本当に力及ばすな部分ありまし
そ次は野菜ゲーム作りたいですいやいい
ですねちょっと画期的なんですけどはい
野菜と野菜がくっつくと大きい野菜になっ
てそれをどんどんこうあの容器に入れてく
ゲームっていうの僕考えたんですけどああ
もうちょっとそれはまた開発の方にも伝え
てちょっと形にできるかあれですけど
ありがとうございますよろしくお願いし
ますすませ当にありがとうございますはい
どうもありがとうございます今まさにお
話しした内容通りでゲームって12年
ぐらいすると本当にトレンドが
めちゃくちゃ変わるんですよなんかそう
いうのもひょっとしたら絡んでるのかなっ
ていう気もしますなかなか最近スマホで
がっつりこうやって横に構えて両手でこう
やるゲームもちろん流行ってるゲームも
ありますけどなんかそういうハイ
クオリティなゲームって今PCとかでやっ
てる人が多いなっていう印象があります
突然まじめになってどうした俺まあ
ちょっと1ゲーム開発に携わったものとし
て本当にたくさんのことが学ぶことができ
ましたちょっとね神流島っていうゲーム
どれぐらい遊んだ方もいらっしゃいますか
遊んでくれる人を増やそうと思って
100万円取りの掴み取り企画もですね
ダウンロードが100万ダウンロードいか
ずに中心になってしまっおります申し訳
ございませんあのゲームをこう見て遊んで
みて僕が思った良かった点と悪かった点を
話したいと思います良かった点はえ長く
時間をかけて作ったんですよキャラクター
や世界観あの禍々しい島そして可愛いけど
も小性のあるキャラクターでストーリー的
な部分の評価ゲームのコンセプトっていう
のは評価かなりいだけてたような気がし
ましたそこはすごく僕良かったなと思い
ます似たような世界観のゲームないんで
そこは唯一無にだと思いますそしてもう1
つが者さんのえお力もいただきまして漫画
化しました上流島第1巻発売中でござい
ますマガポケの方で連載は継続する予定な
のでちょっとぜひあの動画の概要欄から
リンクから見てみてください美少女と
ホラーの漫画でもうあのすごいいいです
ちょっとエロいですそこは続くので是非
あの世界感が気に入ったなって人はそちら
も見てみてくださいあとは鬼川ねあの
ゲームのシステムとしてその追う方が周り
の動物に表意したりこう擬態人に化けたり
島の中に雑魚敵がたくさんいたりとか今
までの非症型のゲームとはちょっと違った
新しいものが作れたのではないかなと思っ
てますここはすごい良かったなという点ま
悪かった点は僕大きく2つかなと思ってて
ま初期のマッチングできないゲームが
そもそも遊べないっていうのとスマホ
ゲームにしてはよくできすぎたあの
クオリティのゲームこう構えてあるのって
すごいやっぱり集中するんで途中で
LINE見る時間とかもないのかなって
いうスマホゲームだったらもっとシンプル
にしても良かったのかなっていうのが
ちょっと思いましたそうねなのでせっかく
世界観とかキャラとか良かっのでもう
ちょっとなんかゲームゴリゴリ要素を
減らしてストーリーとかにフィーチャーし
たものにした方が良かったのかなと思っ
たりあのクオリティのゲームを出すんだっ
たら本当スマホじゃなかったかなっていう
部分は思いました難しいんすよスマホゲー
ムって集中してこうやってスマホゲーム
するのって
すごいなんだろうな今からそういうゲーム
出すのってかなりハードル高いんじゃない
かなと思いました個人的な意見ですよ本当
に個人的にはそう思ったなっていうスマホ
ゲームのあり方ももう日々変わり続けてい
ますはいというのでサービス終了して
しまいましたあすればよかったこうすれば
よかったってのはもうどんどん出てくるん
ですけども上流島自体のコンセプトは僕は
間違ってなかったと思います現に漫画も
続いてます買ってくださいエロいのでいや
だから本当にそのスマホっていうものを
もうちょっと理解いやでも理解してても
このゲームやりましょうてって2年以上
経ってるからそのかに変わっちゃうんだよ
な世界ははじめ社長はこの企画を通して
ゲーム作りの難しさを学びましたはいと
いうわけで遊んでみた今も遊んでいる人昔
遊んでいたちょっとだけ遊んでいた方も
たくさんいると思いますが僕が開発に
携わらせていただきました神流島サービス
終了となりますえサービス終了に伴い未
シオのゲーム内通貨課金俺もめっちゃし
てるわめっちゃしてるわ課金ミオのゲーム
内通過は払い戻しの対応をいたします詳細
は概要欄のリンクからご確認ください下に
あります先ほども言いましたがゲームは
これで終了なんですけども漫画の方は
引き続きマガポケで連載続いております
そして単行本第1巻出てます是非買って見
てみてください動画の概要欄からチェック
できますいやでもなんかすごいなんだろう
な失敗っていうわけでもいやサービス終了
してるから失敗ですねでもね本当に素敵な
世界観というか僕の作りたい世界こういう
ゲームがあって欲しいっていうのは実現
できたかなと思います本当にたくさんの方
に協力していただいて完成した神流ジマと
いうゲームでし
た関わってくださった全ての皆様本当に
ありがとうございましたそして1回でも
遊んでくださった皆様も本当にありがとう
ございましたま今回のこの企画で学んだ
ことを生かしてもしまた機会があればまた
もう少しいいゲームができればいいなと
思います本当に学ぶことが多かったよ
そして世の中の売れてるゲームのすさを
痛感したゲーム作りっていうのは本当に
なんか思いつけでパッとやってうまくいく
もんじゃないのっていうかかなり考えない
といやむずい考えなくても売れるゲームは
売れる
からだから面白えんだろうなちょっと残念
なお知らせにはなったんですがたくさんの
ことを学べたいい機会になりましたこれに
めけずまた機会があればちょっとゲーム
作ってみたいと思います僕はゲーム好きな
のでじゃ
[音楽]
な
ne